So I'm going to talk about confusion matrices.
It's a word you've probably never heard before, but it's good vocabulary if you
want to do machine learning and talk to somebody else about it.
Imagine we have a classifier above this line,
the class tables are red Xs, and below the line we have green circles.
As before, we call the red X as positive examples and
the green circle's negative.
The confusion matrix is a two by two matrix.
It compares the actual class, which can be positive or negative.
With it, we called a predicted class,
it's our output which also can be positive or negative.
And each on the right increments the count on the left.
So let's see.
Let's take a data point over here that is negative, and
that is classified to lie on the green side of the classifier.
If I wanted to count this type of data,
in which of the four buckets on the left would it fall?
Just click on the corresponding pocket.